[Musique]
tapez trente deux ans je me batte pour
sauver cette église au besoin de créer
une richesse et on a une belle
opportunité
si au moins on avait une salle de
concert peut-être que ça passerait mais
des bureaux de luxe
on remet en valeur cette magnifique
église au sein de ces barbares que
demander de plus c'est l'histoire d'une
vieille église anglicane en plein coeur
de saint lambert le village comme
l'appellent les résidents ici
construit dans les années 1880 vendus
aux francs-maçons quarante ans plus tard
le bâtiment de style néo tu dors et déjà
plus que centenaire quand la ville le
rachète à la fin des années 90 et
pendant 15 ans il ne s'est rien passé
c'est trouve ça très décevant qu'un
conseil municipal ne fasse rien devant
une bâtiment comme celui ci qui aurait
pu devenir une très belle maison de la
culture au centre du village
ciré pu avoir des concerts et fort vent
un peu d'imagination en 2017 l'église
est finalement vendu à un fromage et max
dubois pour cent soixante mille dollars
la moitié du prix de l'évaluation les
conditions des ventes était très très
très clair ça besoin d être une
restauration
c'était pas du tout respecté et
maintenant on se trouve face une
dévolution décidées des fils pour
refaire une pastiche des sept édifices
en 2019 deux ans après la transaction
les travaux n'ont toujours pas commencé
par tous les signes de délabrement
s'accumulent à l'extérieur comme à
l'intérieur un nouveau partenaire prend
le projet en main on ne pouvait pas
rénové c'était impossible à rénover
c'est techniquement impossible à rénover
c'est sous son impulsion que les
obligations initial vont être assouplies
avec l'appui du maire ça devenait un
passé pour un promoteur de rentabiliser
ce projet donc il fallait apporter une
modification et c'est pour ça qu'elle
soit acceptée canada pour permettre au
projet de se réaliser
on ne parle plus alors de restauration
mais de reconstruction quelques mètres
plus loin on va quand même reprendre des
matériaux qu'on peut se trouver pour les
réintégrer dans le projet on m'avait
promis d'enlever les vitraux et de les
protéger dans un bâtiment à part soit
sauvé mairie de tout ce qui était promis
qui est s'est réalisé mounir fait lui
trop oric par la pierre aux repères les
arches orphée lieu à patrimoniale tout
en étant libéré de certaines contraintes
notamment à propos des fondations à on
s'excuse
non c'est pas vrai si vous avez pas lu
la bonne affaire parce que il n'est pas
indiqué quand de refaire les fondations
mais c'était bel et bien écrit noir sur
blanc dans l'acte de vente initial signé
en 2017 c'est très triste et de dire la
restauration comme on est en visionner
depuis 30 ans est presque impossible de
les fermer
voici le projet qui doit occuper le
terrain une église rebâti le
savoir-faire plus alimentaire le
commerce de proximité
et puis ça devient comme un hâle ou en
plus avec des animations toutes sortes
et à côté quatre étages de bureaux avec
stationnement souterrain je penserai pas
que ça va être quelque chose qui va
servir à la communauté
c'est un promoteur qui va à du privé y a
pas de garantie la ville jamais exigé
des garanties fermes
c'est ça que je trouve plate avant le
dernier conseil municipal une
consultation publique sur le projet et
ces dérogations a donné lieu à moins de
quarante commentaires majoritairement
négatifs ou 60% d'un échantillon de % de
la population
c'est pas très révélateur du taux
d'acceptation de ce projet nous on a un
feeling qu'elle ce projet là il est il
une très bonne acceptabilité sociale
comité de démolition va rencontrer des
citoyens
on va l'expliquer le promoteur va être
là moi j'ai confiance à la majorité
silencieuse qui vont appuyer le projet
la critique ça fait partie
malheureusement de l'adn de
saint-lambert et cet édifice qui en fait
aussi partie depuis la fin du 19ème
s'apprête à vivre une cure de jouvence
radical
[Musique]
si mathieu prost radio canada saint
lambert